[Music]
yes that word spiritual I think the
reason why many people run away from it
is because lots of what has been done in
the name of spiritual or spirituality
has been completely crazy
so the problem with that words it's easy
for a lot of really bizarre unfounded
sometimes even destructive and toxic
ideas can hang out under this word
spiritual because you're talking
essentially about that which isn't
accessed through the five senses when
somebody says well that well I just had
a spiritual feeling well you can't
really put that on a spreadsheet you you
can't really take a picture of that my
understanding of spirituality is that
this life that we've each been given the
very breath that we took and we're about
to take as a gift that life is a gift
and how you respond to it what you do
with it matters
so you'll find in a business people
working very hard and making lots of
money and yet at some point asking these
questions like what is the point of what
we're doing why are we here why are we
giving this kind of energy to this which
is fundamentally a spiritual question
because the answer that question won't
show up in the second quarter financials
and yet why people get up in the morning
and come work here is the driving
question behind the question behind the
question so I begin with life as a gift
and what you do with it how you respond
to it matters and when we talk about it
mattering we are talking about something
that's true but can't be accessed in the
ways that we normally access things and
I think a lot of scientists have run
from the word spiritual because of
scientist deals with hard facts and when
you get into language of the heart
language of the soul when you start
talking about transcendence you are
talking about more than literal truth so
like if someone who asked me why I fell
in love with my wife
and I said well because she's five seven
she's from Arizona and she drives a
Honda that's kind of a weird answer but
if you say to me why'd you fall in love
with your wife and I said I fell in love
with Kristen because when we got
together it was like I found my other
half something within you was like okay
now that's that's now that's an answer
that I get I I understand that answer
and yet it's not like I was limping it's
not like suddenly I actually literally
found my other half I shifted to a
different kind of language to describe a
different kind of reality and so
oftentimes in my experience the
scientist is fine with spirituality when
we understand the terms that we're
working with this idea somehow that
faith and science are in opposition I've
always found to be complete insanity
both are searching for the truth both
have a sense of wonder and an
expectation and exploration they're each
simply naming different aspects of the
human experience
one thrives in naming exterior 'he's
height weight gravitational pole
electromagnetic force the other is about
naming interiors compassion kindness
suffering loss heartache
they're both simply different ways of
exploring different dimensions of the
human experience well if you think about
the past like such say 3 400 years of
human history especially the history of
the Western world we've had this
explosion some call it the age of
certainty the explosion of scientific
rationalism I mean we have 10,000 songs
in our pockets we have airports and
hospitals we don't have polio anymore I
mean we have had this explosion of
rational stand at a distance and study
and analyze it with a clipboard and a
lab coat
I guess now will be an iPad but we've
had this explosion of knowledge about
how the world actually works and so for
many people this rational linear
scientific thinking has done so
much that it sort of stepped on and
crowded out other ways of knowing things
because I was doing this event recently
and a woman came up afterwards and she
had a little child in one of those
little packs that you carry a child
around and it was a Saturday and she
said yesterday I found out that my
child's been diagnosed with MS and then
she turns and walks away
there isn't a formula or a theorem to
name what she's going through what she
needs is a poem she needs a prayer a
liturgy a song she needs a ritual you
light a candle you sit in silence with
somebody when it comes to grief pain
loss heartbreak euphoria joy ecstasy the
lab and the microscope and the data
aren't as helpful so I think what's
happening in the modern age is people
are realizing we've built this
extraordinary gleaming modern world and
yet we're more hungry and thirsty for
meaning than ever so I think that's
what's happening is we have more than
any human beings had ever had in the
history of the world and yet the same
questions are still gnaw at the soul
what's it mean what are we doing here
what is joy found everything is driven
by the desire to know the truth there's
an exploration there's a wide-eyed sense
of wonder if you talk to the best
scientists they have this sort of gleam
in their eye like this is what we're
learning and we don't know what's
actually around the corner and if you
talk to the best theologians and poets
and scholars they ideally have the same
gleam in their eye which is look what
we're learning look what we're exploring
and so to me they're not enemies they're
long-lost dance partners and I actually
think what's happening right now is if
you and I on are in opposition if we
have some sort of fight and we turn and
walk away from each other if we walk
away from each other long enough we'll
probably go around the globe and we'll
meet up on the other side and so I think
for many people especially religious
people who are raised with this sort of
faith and religion going in opposite
directions I think what's happening is
there
coming back around and we're realizing
these are all ways of exploring
different dimensions of the human
experience
[Music]